how's it goin everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course everything relating
to the MCU today we have a lot of news
about the next Avengers film over the
weekend a lot of news came out about
what could possibly happen right before
the New Avengers and the Young Avengers
could come into play in the MCU and
apparently according to these reports
spider-man is going to be in the MCU for
a while and he is going to be at the
center of the New Avengers and even the
young Avengers
so he is essentially just like they
talked about in spider-man far from home
going to be the new Iron Man not taking
on his armor but taking on the
responsibilities so let's break down
everything that we know also be sure to
subscribe when notifications turned on
to stay up to date with MCU and keep a
lookout for my giveaway winner video
it'll be coming out in a couple of days
so recently Marvel's phase four slate
got switched around a little bit due to
Marvel Studios having to push some
movies back due to the corona virus and
when this happened we got an actual date
for Captain Marvel 2 and that is July of
2022 and according to Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige Captain Marvel 2
is going to play a major role in the New
Avengers team moving forward and
according to today's report she's going
to play an even bigger role in setting
up what happens in the New Avengers film
that we're going to be getting in a few
years according to a report from MCU
cosmic comm there is a rumor going
around right now that Captain Marvel 2
is meant to set the stage for whatever
story the New Avengers movie will tell
this is going to be much like how
Captain America Civil War was Captain
America's Civil War in 2016 set up
Avengers in game and the status of the
Avengers when we left the Avengers and
Captain America Civil War they were
divided the civil war between them kind
of tore them apart and that's how they
were in the beginning and all throughout
Avengers infinity war it wasn't until
Avengers and game until they all came
together
well apparently Captain Marvel 2 is
going to serve the same purpose
whatever happens in Captain Marvel 2 is
going to bleed into the beginning or
maybe all throughout the next Avengers
film the New Avengers so Captain Marvel
2 is going to be an extremely important
movie for the next Avengers film but
apparently
so is spider-man 3 also coming from MCU
cosmic comm a report states that
spider-man will indeed be in the New
Avengers film and since spider-man is
supposed to be one of the new leaders of
the New Avengers team this comes as
little to no surprise however it appears
that there are more plans for spider-man
than just the New Avengers team
according to a new rumor going around
spider-man is going to be in charge of
The Young Avengers
this means that we could possibly be
seen spider-man in a Disney Plus show
right now it's rumored that the
direction that they're going to be
taking with the Young Avengers is going
to be the Disney Plus route and of
course as Kevin Feige mentioned the
characters from the Disney Plus shows
are going to be in the movies as well
and in fact if you aren't watching the
Disney Plus shows Kevin Feige has stated
that you're not going to know what's
going on in the movies
so the Young Avengers are going to play
a pretty big role in the MCU at some
point and it appears that not only is
spider-man 3 going to tie into the New
Avengers film but it's also going to tie
into the Young Avengers in fact the New
Avengers Park that is going to be coming
to Disney has several Young Avengers
they're on display and spider-man is
their leader
so it appears that they are preparing
for spider-man to be the future leader
of the Young Avengers this means that
whatever New Deal that Sony and Marvel
and Disney worked out it means that
spider-man is going to be in the MCU for
a pretty long time and not only is he
going to be a major leader for the new
Avengers but also the Young Avengers as
well and also in this report is news
about the possible new director of the
New Avengers MCU cosmic hinted at the
directors who are being considered to
helm the next Avengers project saying
that one of the names being discussed
would be a huge fan favorite
due to spider-man being in the movie now
the first thing that comes to mind of
course is Sam Raimi the director of the
original spider-man trilogy he has
recently been brought aboard Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness to
direct that film so it wouldn't be that
far-fetched to think that Marvel Studios
could be eyeing him to direct a new
Avengers film after all we know that the
multiverse of madness is going to
introduce the multiverse in various
different universes in the MCU
and that is most likely going to play a
pretty big role in the MCS future moving
forward and the New Avengers film so
what better director to have for the new
Avengers
than the director that will introduce
the multiverse in multiverse of madness
so for those of you who may not be
excited about a new Avengers film it may
be more exciting and even crazier than
we thought it was going to be with
Captain Marvel and spider-man leading
the team and of course when the x-men
the Fantastic Four and the Young
Avengers all come together in the MCU as
well things are going to get very very
exciting so let me know what you think
about this news and let me know who you
would like to see on the new Avengers
team but when we finally get the movie
let me know your thoughts and the
comments down below and don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to stay up
to date on all content relating to
Marvel you can follow me on Twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll fall off